alright the winner is Oh Keith Irvin
again how special is this award for you
you say everything I mean that's that's
why we do what we do you just make music
and hope it connects with everybody so
when songs like blue inch colour and the
fighter do what they do it's it's
phenomenal
now how many trophies is there tonight
for ya it's never happened to me ever so
yeah so always other people so it's an
amazing feeling yeah and winning for the
fighter specifically tell me about
sharing that award with Kerry and what
that means yeah and a big shout-out to
Busby who wrote the song with as well
awesome and I'm so glad for her winning
female as well but we had a blast
shooting that video being able to just
work with her and we were really lucky
too because we had just done a tour
together before we shot the video so it
was super easy to be on on camera with
her
[Music]
so any thoughts now on how you celebrate
tonight the change things from on the
red carpet early yeah I don't know I
don't know it's um more than I could
have ever imagined yeah yeah
congratulate and it's all the fans so
thank you very much everything thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]